[Music]
[Music]
I'm contributing photographer to
National Geographic magazine I
relentlessly wanna understand things and
particularly things that are not part of
my sort of orbit of perception
[Music]
I'm in Texas with the Hughes family
seeing what life is like here
[Music]
I'm interested in how boys learn to
become men
in different parts of the world
[Applause]
certainly like a critical element of
historic notions of masculinity has been
overcoming fear I have no idea how I'm
going to take the pictures of the bull
riding I have no idea this story has an
aspect of it that is pretty unfamiliar
to me which is kind of like sports
photography I don't use long lenses I
don't know how exactly I'm gonna handle
this thing that happens like very
quickly
[Music]
I don't think I got it I know I thought
all the elements you know the halogen
light the wide-open awkward space I
thought it'd all be magic she's always
I've really strived to explore larger
subjects through individual stories so
rodeo is a way in to something else a
way in to looking at Riggin rowdy and
Ridge hues and what their lives are like
how are these boys growing up it's a
very different kind of experience than I
had growing up and that I think in a lot
of ways is what propels me to be as
curious as I am about these things I
want to understand things outside of the
world that shaped and informed my
outlooks
[Music]
the actual act of photography I think is
fairly intuitive the pictures that I
feel end up resonating the best are
pictures that were made in situations
where it's like I am I'm barely
conscious of what's happening photos are
imbued with a lot and they're shaped and
determined by where the photographer
stands and the moment that the
photographer chooses and that's a lot of
responsibility because as a photographer
you choose
[Music]
[Applause]
good job baby
[Music]
I think the image that a lot of people
have in their mind of ranch life in this
part of Texas is the hats and horses but
Kelly influence I think of presenting
their sons with a pretty dynamic set of
learning experiences as boys and young
men
[Music]